- I think there's a
kind of a misconception
that Bitcoin is
completely anonymous.
It's really pseudo anonymous.
If a state actor or
even a big corporation
wants to find out who
transferred Bitcoin to whom
it can be done.
It's harder than just
looking at someone's Visa
or bank account but, I think,
there are new technologies
built on top of Bitcoin,
like the lightning network,
that for very small amounts
will keep it almost like cash
where it will be much harder
and won't be worth the effort.
(intense music)
- All right, I'm Dave Rubin.
We are on location in Miami.
I am with Alex Lloyd,
co author of The
Little Bitcoin Book:
Why Bitcoin Matters For Your
Freedom, Finances, and Future.
We're obviously in the
right city for that,
so Lloyd, why does it matter?
- You know we came at this book
from a human rights perspective.
One of my co-authors,
Alex Gladstein,
is the Chief Strategy Officer
of the Human Rights Foundation
and there were a lot
of books out there
about the technical nature
and the financial nature
of why Bitcoin's important.
This one really gives more
a sociopolitical aspect,
why everyday people,
Bitcoin is going to
be important to them
and that's kind of
the angle we took.
- So, we talked about
this a little bit
at dinner last night, I mean,
basically you think
Bitcoin will free people
as these systems
around us go down.
Is that fair to say?
- I think what it is is it's
a democratization of capital.
If you think of the history
of how individuals got
more power in the world,
it started with democracy.
There's a lot of steps here,
but democracy as a
political system.
I think, another step
that you might think of
is freedom of speech
and the internet,
which let anybody be a
publisher and a creator
and I think Bitcoin
is the next step,
which is people can
be their own banks
and have their own
individual freedom.
Whereas the internet,
in a way, was a way
to let any two people exchange
ideas and information,
and Bitcoin is going to be a way
that any two people
can exchange value
and that's a big
part of this book.
- Since most of my audience
is pretty tech savvy,
but not everybody,
for the person that's
watching this right now
that has no Bitcoin.
They've heard the word Bitcoin,
they're like, what
the hell is Bitcoin?
It's not backed by anything,
what is this thing?
Give me me the Q and
A portion of this
'cause you guys end this,
chapter six is all a Q
and A about the basics.
- I think if you think
of, as Americans,
a lot of people don't
understand the privilege we have
in terms of the amount
of financial resources,
banks, credit card, Apple
Pay, all these systems that,
PayPal, that let us exchange
value between people
but billions of people
across the world
don't have any such technology.
They probably will never
have a bank account
and Bitcoin is way for them
to, in a way, be their own bank
and in an unstoppable way
exchange value with anybody
across the whole world
and, I think, that's the message
that really makes Bitcoin not
this crazy trading scheme.
A lot of people think it's
just like a Ponzi scheme
but this is, if you think about
it, it's a way for people,
billions of people to
exchange and store value
without having any
government or company
involved in it and that's
a very powerful idea.
- What about the other cryptos,
where do they fit into this?
The other coins?
- This book is really
focused on Bitcoin.
I think there's a place
for a lot of other
types of technology
and Bitcoin is an
evolving thing,
there's going to be other
things that graft onto it
like the lightning network,
so, you'll be able to do
millions or billions
of transactions a day.
But Bitcoin in and of itself
is really the preeminent way
to store value in an exchange.
It was really designed
in an amazingly smart way
and the book goes into
why it's different
from any previous type of money.
- Can you explain the difference
between why you would
use Bitcoin to store
versus necessarily using it
as what you're buying with,
basically, all the time?
- Well, I think that
as it stands now,
Bitcoin is probably not
the best way to buy things
just because there's
millions of other,
easier ways to exchange value.
If you're in the United
States or Europe,
a company that has
a banking system,
but what we've seen
is there are human rights
advocates throughout the world
who live in dictatorships
and they have no way
of safely storing
anything that they create
in terms of value.
And if they store cash
under their mattress,
that can get taken,
if they have money in
their bank account,
that could get taken by
the government by fear
but, what's even worse,
a lot of countries
have hyperinflation,
so that's just an insidious way
of stealing money from people
without them really noticing
it in the short term.
- That's kind of where
we're going right now.
- It's possible and that's
maybe a bigger case for Bitcoin.
But Bitcoin is the first
time that people...
The Human Rights
Foundation does give grants
to human rights advocates
throughout the world
and before it was a multi-step
process that took days
and was fraught with peril in
terms of getting them capital.
And now, through Bitcoin,
there's really a simple way
that we can send people capital
and they can use it and
store it in a safe way
and that's really never
been possible before.
- Right, so basically,
Human Rights Foundation,
you can find people
that are doing good
work in some country,
trying to free people,
whatever, whatever it is
and then you can
send them Bitcoin
and that way whatever
work they're doing,
that the government is not
probably thrilled with,
it's theirs and the
government, technically,
it doesn't even know about it.
- Exactly.
- Should we be talking
about that right now, or?
- Like what, the government
not knowing about it?
I think there's a misconception
that Bitcoin is
completely anonymous.
It's really pseudo anonymous.
If a state actor or
even a big corporation
wants to find out who
transferred Bitcoin to whom
it can be done.
It's harder than just
looking at someone's visa
or bank account but, I think,
there are new technologies
built on top of Bitcoin,
like the lightning network,
that for very small amounts
will keep it almost like cash
where it'll be much harder
and won't be worth
the effort to track.
- How's this all connected
to just decentralizing
everything?
You know, the world I'm in
where everybody's worried
that if you put a video up
that YouTube doesn't like
you're going down.
Or if you put a Tweet up
that Twitter doesn't like,
they're going to get rid of you.
Just the general
decentralization idea.
- I think this was the proof,
the first technology that
really proved it could work
and the designer or inventor
of Bitcoin was really smart
in terms of creating an
amazing incentive network
where hundreds of
millions of dollars
has been invested in the
blockchain technology
and the mining around it
without really any investment
from government or
venture capitalists.
- Can you give me mining 101
for people that
don't get it at all?
- Bitcoin is all about proving
that what's in the
public ledger is accurate
and there's two parts of that.
One is basically proving
that having thousands
of independent computers
and people running
those computers,
check to see that that
ledger is correct.
And then the other is
finding new Bitcoin
and that's proving
the work that you did
enables the incentive
structure to be set up
so that Bitcoin can be created.
- Right, what about when Elon
Musk is like, I'm into it
and it goes like this, and
then he's like, I'm not into it
and it goes like this
and then that gets
people all freaked out.
- I feel like he's having fun.
He's a very smart guy,
he's created some really
incredible technologies
but he's also someone
who probably likes
to troll a lot
on Twitter.
- You think, you think?
- And he also runs a company
that is very focused on green,
which is Tesla and I'm
sure he got pushed back
saying Bitcoin isn't
green, which I think it is
because a majority,
70% of the Bitcoin,
is mined from renewable sources
because people are really
looking for the cheapest energy
when they mine a Bitcoin
and that's, typically,
renewable stuff.
- Right, but can you
power it by volcanoes?
Isn't that what the
President of El Salvador
is trying to do?
- We will see.
I hope it works.
- Is that
literally what he's trying
to do, it seemed like a joke?
- Well, if you think about where
Bitcoin mining takes place,
it needs a power source and if
you create a huge solar cell
in the middle of
the Sahara Desert,
it's not really valuable energy
because you have to then
ship that energy to a city.
But if you created a
huge green solar plant
in the middle of
this Sahara Desert
and your output was new Bitcoin,
that might be a financially
viable situations
because you can just email out
the new Bitcoin that you create
and the output is not a
huge cable pumping power,
it's just some numbers.
- Right, for somebody
watching this, that's like,
all right, I didn't know
much about it before
I got some basics here.
Where do they start
with all this?
Do you send them to a wallet
to start, an exchange,
where do you send people?
- There's a lot of
different ways and, I think,
everybody is going to
have a different approach.
You can go to a centrally
stored wallet, like Coinbase.
You can also have
an app on your phone
where you store stuff.
You could have a USB stick
And I think the
major difference,
and maybe a lot of people don't
wrap their head around it,
is that you're your own bank,
so that gives you
a lot of freedom
but then it gives you
some responsibilities
because you have
to be the person
who creates the wall
around your privacy
and you have responsibilities
when you get that freedom.
- So that stick that
I have in a safe
and the password and all that,
I can't lose that, right?
- You can't lose that.
- That's the key to this thing,
don't lose the password?
- And you don't
want to post your password.
- Don't post it?
- Don't have it on the back of
your computer written there,
and then you take a selfie
and then everybody can see it
'cause then the Bitcoin's gone.
- I'm gonna have to
scribble that down.
All right, I want to talk to
you about one other thing,
which is that you basically
were the first
big guy in Locals.
You helped us put this
whole thing together
and connected us with
a ton of investors.
You opened up a
million doors for us.
So I guess my question is
what did you see in
what we were doing
because we talked to a lot
of people at the beginning.
A lot of people said,
it's a good idea,
but you know it could
be a little dangerous
and freeing people and all that.
It made some people scared but
you were like, let's do it.
- Well, I have to admit,
the reason I took
a meeting with you
is because I was a
fan of your work.
So I like the way you think
and I was like, well,
how bad can it be?
I can meet this guy and it'll
be interesting conversation.
But then when you described it
in terms of giving power
back to the creator
and having a system where it's,
I think, unfortunately, a
lot of times in our society,
there's big tech companies
that have gotten a little
bit too much power.
And I really liked your
David versus Google
Goliath approach to things.
And when I make a decision
to invest in a company
it's really about the team
and your team with this
offer was really impressive
and the technology
we're building
was right on what I
thought could work.
And then it's proven
really to be true
and I have seen so many creators
thrive on your platform.
They can quit their day
job and just be on Locals
and have an amazing life
and just continue to create
and that's impossible
on other platforms.
So, I think I've
been proven right
that investing in
you and your team
has been a really good thing.
- What's the funnest
part of doing this,
watching these companies grow
and you've had some nice wins?
- I love entrepreneurs.
I think they're all
a little bit crazy,
they take these crazy risks
and it's really amazing
to see it pay off.
No sane person wants
to be an entrepreneur
but it's that good kind of crazy
taking on these intractable
problems and building something
and, to me, that's the most
fun, it's the human aspect.
And I am kind of
a computer geek,
I love all the
technology aspects of it.
I'm a science fiction fan
and I love the idea of seeing
how Sci-Fi will play
out in the real world
and what are the trends
that are going to work,
have impact on society?
- We're basically in a
dystopian future right now.
- Sometimes I think that
we live in a simulation
because craziest
stuff is happening.
- So my last question
for you, we're in Miami.
You moved to Miami,
so you're a case of you
lived in San Francisco.
How long did you live
in San Francisco?
- 23 years.
- Yeah, 23 years, you just
moved here in the last year.
Beautiful wife, beautiful
kids, thriving here.
You think I'm nuts
we're not leaving yet?
- You know, take your time,
Miami will still be here
but definitely move
here before your IPO.
- True wisdom from a great
man and a great investor,
Alex Lloyd.
Thanks a lot, man.
- Thank you.
- Nice.
If you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our tech playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist,
they're right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.